こんにちははじめ社長ですいうわけで夏ですね夏といえばもうあれしかないでしょ
鍵ゴールデンで今日こちらの書き方劇を準備したんですけどもうもう普通の加入皆でも
僕26年食ってますけども言える毎年行ってるかもしれないんですけどもうちょっと
変わったかき氷を作ろうと思いまして今回はこちら
ねるねるねるねをたくさん準備させていただきま
したこれで大体何するかわかった人多いと思うんですけど
ナンですねトルコ風アイスって皆さん知ってますでしょうか[ __ ]普通大事だとこのが
映っ
ってなるんですけどプロ工夫あいつはぽいってやるとなんかにゃんって伸びて2000
ピョンってなるんですよ
それが美味しいですよ鍵後でも最新の機械だったらなんかシャリシャリの化によりより
いくバトル学費をよ目指してるのが多かったんで
ねるねるねるねモデル濡れねろねろなんてわざわざねるねローンを作るかき氷てを買わ
なくても練りに練るを使えば寝るで狙うの鍵よりが膨れる
思うのね今日は寝るんでな音ができる席後でが作れれば毒はメールで胸の使って続けて
いきたいとおもいます
ん
びゃーコミ本的な作っていきましょう
めんどくさん番号がで123で全部入れていけばいいと思うんですねでは早速作って
いくよ
一番のこの本難いですね三角カップにお水を入れます
大隊大隊に選んだいたいですねまぁ zimmer
全然みんなこれが見たいわけじゃないんだよなぁをつけてその結果が知りたいと思って
ちょっとでもやってきたに作ってくわー
まあそうだな見てもこれねるねるねるねローンですよこれも完全にイッ
4 f
んでー
2つまえん
バレないバーがあふれゆえ今回の目的はこの寝るデーの使ってかき氷を作ることです
からね続けます
山正樹で全部食っちまいましたこれでもうフラートンの音でレベルの奴のかき氷ができ
たらマジでおいしいと思うよね作る過程ああもう全部一緒なんでまとめて月園と一つの
容器に作っていきたいと思いますすみません言い忘れてました丹波んだこのはこれ
キャンディーのトッピングなんで開き氷を作るのが目的なんですよねこれはちょっと
あの最後にかけるぐらいにしておこうと思います
[音楽]
ん
いっぱいじゃなぜていこう飛べますぞきっ
1月
[拍手]
はい的でできました結構な量になりましたね
めっちゃトロリーしてるんでこれで夏季号に作ったらまずでトロトロのトルコ不具合
素敵な裂き織りができるんじゃないかなと思いますが高くかき氷の容器に入れていき
ましょう
ウィンド種
me
ん
あってやばくないそれはやばいねはい
大臣はこれで ok だと思います一応予備でもう一個作っておきましょうこれ失敗
すると笑えないんでめっちゃ場といるような気がしますぞこれ
のこれは食べておきますには完璧でしょ開いてきて無事かき氷機に入る大きさに
エネルギーを作りました
ただして登録風アイスの夜中奪ったなどと書き方に簡単につくることができるん
でしょうか
目がぁああああ
rar
はいというで傾向を時間経ちましたもうタッチ数に凍っておりますレイズまで甘い的
ふわっとろっと姉待って
凍ってることでコってパットにめっちゃ凍ってないかが出る言葉忘れました
ん
こうすることでだいぶスポットのスポットバスタブなんかねまでは捨てるんだって動い
てバレなんだろうなったら液体と固体の間みたいな感じなんでちゃんとこうれない
みたいなちょっと多分本人的にはかなり悔しい思いをしているのではないかなと思って
おりますではつけて来ない
こっち頭いいんでしょううわなんかやばい黒いブログを a にゃ
ピットいいんねこれ本当にできるんだないきます go
[拍手]
うん
[音楽]
すわとろん
me
teame
wh 8版
なんでやもう見て立ってば負担だと見たら別れてもですめっちゃちゃんと凍ってるん
ですよ
なんでねるねーでって凍らないの
何ケットっています食べたんですけどコーラないっぽいですねコールんですけどなんか
凍ってもだからやっぱりねばねましてかき氷機に入るような硬さには行ったらない
みたいなことが今が分かりました
次に入ってああああああゲイリー言っていうギターマンでもこうたね寝るでも
美味しいので ok です